une des conséquences de la neige et du
verglas il est moins facile de passer
son permis de conduire depuis le début
de la semaine des reports de cours et
des annulations de dernière minute sont
constatés comme dans cette auto école le
problème qui se passe c'est pour les
élèves qui sont en préparation d'examens
qui sont proches de l'examen puisque
déjà on a des difficultés pour les
préparer et surtout on ne peut pas
savoir à l'avancé si le l'examen aura
lieu ou non les élèves qui pourrait
faute d'un accord avec les auto-écoles
être amenés à payer des heures de
conduite en plus le problème de la neige
associée depuis mardi à la grève des
inspecteurs du permis de conduire qui
protestent contre le nouveau permis
européen
mise en place depuis le 19 janvier dans
cette auto écoles de montigny en tout
cas la grève n'a pas eu d'impact